so it has something to do with perhaps
say general anxiety of making meaning in
a time that seems meaningless or maybe
even timeless
[Music]
so how does all Nostalgia for the past
influence our dreams to the Future
influence our psychology our life and
politics in the present and I'm
particularly conscious of this at a time
where our Nostalgia of the past seems to
correlate with a growing populism across
Europe on one hand you have a Nostalgia
for a whiter more homogeneous largely
male artistic output and in absolutely
correlation No Doubt with no uh
explanatory variable arise in populist
far-right fascistic groups and thinking
um
Grafton is there any connection there
yeah totally and you know the thing is
is most psychological research on
Nostalgia indicates that it's a
pro-social emotion it's healthy it
enables good feelings it builds
communities and the crazy thing is that
doesn't seem to square
with the way that we see nostalgia in
politics maybe which is
um the make America great again sort of
thing at least here in the United States
and that I think that's because
Nostalgia might be really a powerful
emotion at bringing people together but
it might bring them together over not so
good commonalities terrible
commonalities like shared uh you know
anti-immigrant or racist sentiment or
anti-trans gender sentiment or something
but the thing is is we can't cure
Nostalgia out of people and politicians
know this and this is why they use it
along with anger and fear and a number
of other emotions in order to
mobilize groups of people and and divide
and conquer so to speak and the right
wing has been really good recently at uh
not really relying so much on hope for a
future but perhaps a Nostalgia for a
Utopia in the past or what zigmund
Bauman might have called a retro
Topia so there is a weird disconnect in
that if you look just at the
psychological literature it looks like
it's a great emotion nothing wrong with
it but obviously like any emotion that
could be weaponized uh towards dangerous
and destructive ends
um Stu would you make a distinction
based off what grafton's been saying
between Nostalgia
um within and how that's
instrumentalized by some in politics and
Nostalgia within the artistic yeah so so
I've certainly seen it in in politics
and you know it's going to be open about
it I've seen the Tory party use a lot of
um I'm very changing to imagery you know
and uh I've seen a lot of this sort of
Patriotic War like back to the 1940s get
together nuclear families type stuff and
it raises alarm Bells with me massively
um so yeah I totally get a Grafton
saying that I completely agree
um in the Arts
um not so much so I mean every now and
then there's a sort of not there's a
kind of thing where we
we'd bang on oh abstraction was great
everyone's making abstract paintings no
they were and figurative paintings are
back it you know and we have this
argument all the time but um I still
think you know fundamentally within the
Arts you still have your grades you know
David Bowie is always going to be great
like we can just agree that it's a fact
um and it's a different thing but if we
keep listening to David Bowie do we stop
making space for the new David Bowie's
who might be hungry well absolutely not
because if we listen to David Bowie a
lot we'll probably make better music
because you can learn a lot from him
yeah that's not the issue it's not the
issue that just listening to it is
suddenly going to keep us stuck in the
past I mean uh yeah I mean I think that
some of this issue with like the
classics feeling them like their
towering presence Press On Us From the
Past uh has a little bit less to do with
like they don't make good art anymore
and has a little bit more to do with
what was identified 30 Years Ago by this
Anthropologist named Marco Jay about
this crisis in making meaning that
everything now has to have some kind of
meaning there has to be sort of a uh a
grand response out of lots of people who
can then like give their opinion on it
you know and this is how we think it was
back in the old days with the wars and
the great works you know and now there
seems to be this Panic like well where
is the next great big thing in like Mark
Fisher said if it happened long ago how
long ago was it and did we miss it so it
has something to do with perhaps say
general anxiety of making meaning in a
time that seems meaningless or maybe
even timeless
Jenny do you want to come in here on
Nostalgia the past and how it's
influencing current psychology and
politics
you know we went through brexit which I
found probably the most bizarre thing
politically that ever happened in my
lifetime
um because I did look back to the 70s
when we joined the European Union and I
was
a post-war baby who remembered standing
in my grandmother's bay window in the
bedroom and my mother describing to me
how she had stood there during the war
and watched
Sheffield burn because it had been so
badly bombed and that image stood with
me right the way through my childhood my
teenage and into my early 20s which is
what I was when we finally did join the
European Union and that felt to me
something
to be as I got into my late 60s when the
whole brexit debate started that was
something to be powerfully nostalgic
about that feeling of coming
I was in France actually when it
happened because my degree was in in
French
and I came back and wanted to buy fish
and chips as one tends to when one's
comes to England from abroad
and I had money in my hand which was my
own country's currency and I didn't know
what to do with it I I was told it was
65 Pence and I just handed it over it if
I were in a foreign country but it felt
so special that we had now gone decimal
we were just like everybody in Europe
and we were not gonna fight anymore
there wasn't going to be another war and
that was so precious to me and I am now
very very nostalgic for that period and
that feeling of being part of something
bigger something valuable something
where we could travel where we could be
part of Europe and not just this tight
little Island
that there might be a few people feeling
nostalgic for um when you uh didn't need
a visa to go to France for more than
three months at a time
um do I I do want to uh push a little
bit more on this question of the
Nostalgia
um and the extent to which
um The Nostalgia that we have for past
artistic Works can serve to idealize
certain eras so is there ever a risk
that our idealization of certain uh
artistic rates
um can lead to the perception that those
are the only true barometers of that
culture's output and what I mean by that
is you know for example think of your
school curriculum and the books that end
up being the classics right and the
struggles that
um some teachers have been trying to say
well you know we need a few new names on
the on the classic list maybe to
recognize that actually there have been
a whole lot of new authors who come
through who produced extraordinary work
in holding on to only a certain vision
of what the classics are constituted by
we maintain a vision of who we are as a
nation so I mean is there something
about the artists that we consider to be
Classics which is in itself and a
Nostalgia that we don't want to admit
for a past that was maybe less contested
but I think I think the problem there is
it's just with with how history has been
reported
you know I think I think history has
been
misappropriated you know we look at
abstract expressionism as a movement and
there's no women and then the Royal
Academy don't do the the amazing show
that I managed to see in America of
female abstract expressionists right
that were working at the time and and
you know we need to address that but
that's the problem with historicizing
the past and the way that the past is
regurgitated when we're talking about
Nostalgia I actually think it's
something a bit different it's actually
about an emotional sense of meaning that
can be deported into the present moment
and that's a totally different thing and
to grafton's point that may that gives
the artist a utility something that we
can build upon we already understand we
know what it meant you know but but the
problem is that emotionally we say the
60s and you know we picture the mini
skirt and and you get these these
historic bubbles
um but there's nothing to stop us
reinterpreting them and adding to them
but that's the job for the history
teachers
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas